hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
update on the laboratory diagnosis of
lyme and other tick-borne diseases
i am jennifer woods of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
diasoren molecular llc to learn more
visit molecular.deosorin.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
philip molloy
medical director tick-borne diseases
east side clinical laboratory
east providence rhode island dr molloy
you may now begin your presentation
thank you jennifer and i would like to
add my welcome to the audience thank you
for all joining in today
hope you find this presentation
interesting and useful
as we wade through the sometimes
confusing waters of diagnosing
tbd's tick-borne diseases the objectives
today
are to reinforce
remind you about the increasing
prevalence of tick-borne diseases
led by lyme disease followed by the
other emerging agents
i want to take this time to introduce
abbreviations
which there's no shortcut i think you're
going to have to get used to
these terms mtt and sttt
i'll explain that in a minute these are
the paradigms these are the names of the
tests we use for serologic
diagnosis for tick-borne diseases the
last objective
is to reinforce a topic called
co-infections a single tick can carry
multiple pathogens
and a single victim person bit by that
tick
can come down with more than one disease
at a time not at all unusual to see a
patient with lyme plus
babesia lyme plus anaplasma or any of
the
permutations so let's talk about these
things
here are some references here for your
review
i'm reminded also that this talk will be
archived and able to be viewed later
but these are important current and
up-to-date
um references focusing on lyme disease
less so on the other agents lyme is
where most of our
confusion comes from so this is who i am
i hope you can um
take your own time to read this i'm
putting this up to convince you that i
am experienced and credible i hope
i did my training when i was a young
doctor with dr
alan steer the discoverer of lyme
disease in 1976 in lyme connecticut
i have been the medical director for
tick-borne diseases
at several laboratories over the years
at the same time that i am a clinician
and see patients in lyme
and tick-borne highly endemic areas
south coastal massachusetts
cape cod nantucket places i still work
today
and i've been involved with research
over the years
and i put this up because a lot of
people don't realize that the besia is
an
important pathogen transmitted
via blood donation being screened for
now
and berelia miyamoto was a brand new
previously unknown pathogen that was
discovered in our lab the first case in
north america was discovered in 2012
and published a few times so these are
the ticks this is exedy's ticks
going from left to right um engorged
adults nymphal and larval stages of the
tick
on the right side uh the size is the
nymphal ticks or the larval ticks right
now or the ones that are out there
they're about if you took your ballpoint
pen and made a dot on a white piece of
paper that's about how big these sticks
are now
this enforces how easy it is to overlook
these ticks
their bites are frequently totally
asymptomatic
and in places that you don't see which
is why we get these conditions
here are the infections the tbd's
the tick-borne diseases we'll be talking
about today
in the first column is the name of the
organism
in the second column the name of the
disease
the lingo we use there is a column on
the right that talks about abbreviations
and in the far column i wrote down the
years that these
that the first human cases were
discovered
so lyme disease was discovered
in 1976 medical history is very
interesting
we don't have time to talk about the
fascinating ways that these diseases
were finally solved and stumbled upon
and the most recent pathogen on this
list
bralia miyamoto the first cases in
humans in the world
were in 2011 in russia in the first case
as i previously mentioned
in north america was in 2012 late 2012
published in
2013. so here are the ticks
that transmit these tbds tick-borne
diseases to us
and you could classify them in different
ways the
question in the upper right says which
infection doesn't
fit in with the others and of course the
way this slide is set up
is to call attention to you
that hme human monocytic
erlechiosis or just erlechiosis is
transmitted by a totally different tick
than the common deer tick that we're all
used to
the dot on the back of that tick
reminded someone of a lone star that's
where the tick's name come from has
nothing to do with this tech
check being from texas which is not
the reason it's important to know that
different vectors
transmit different tbds is because
in different regions of the country some
chicks are more prevalent than others
some regions of this country have no
deer ticks you can't get any of the deer
trick
transmitted diseases unless there is the
vector there
there are large parts of this country
most of the western half of this country
with a lone star tick is not found
so you can't get hme in those regions
it's important to know a little bit
about your local epidemiology
there's another way to ask that question
which disease
doesn't fit in with the others the top
three on this slide are all
and babesia is not a bacteria it is a
parasite so everyone knows i believe
that lime
is called the germ that causes lyme is
borrelia burgdorferi
it is a spiral shaped spirochetal
bacteria anaplasma enterolichia
are bacteria closer to the rickettsia
family
you'll also see from this slide and i'll
just go right to the next slide
the asterix next to the three bottom
pathogens
is important because those three
pathogens in the bottom live as you can
see
in blood cells granulocytes monocytes
and erythrocytes or red blood cells
is that important yes it's important
because you can find these
in a purple top tube in a specimen of
whole blood
an easy place to look for anaplasma
erlichia and babesia is directly in red
blood cells
or monocytes or granulocytes you can
actually visualize these
organisms in a blood smear
in contrast lyme disease believe bird
dorfry
is not trophic for blood tissue
and is rarely not impossible but rarely
able to be demonstrated in blood
it likes certain tissues skin joints
neurologic tissue but doesn't like to
live in your blood
so the important thing in the way of
diagnosing these
infections is to know that some of these
it's a very good fruitful place
to look for them is right in the blood
cells
so here is a map of the united states
this is lyme disease prevalence
if you looked at the map of lyme disease
prevalence
and compared it to five years ago or 10
years ago or 15 years ago you would see
how much
it has gotten denser more cases and it
has expanded
10 years ago you wouldn't see all these
dots in maine
new hampshire northern new england
states
and it wouldn't be drifting as far south
all the way down
pennsylvania virginia but it's very much
expanded right now
the other pathogens you'll notice that
the deer tick
transmitted pathogens on the top three
maps lyme disease benesiosis and
anaplasmosis since they're transmitted
by the same vector they share a lot of
geographic distributions
in contrast to erlochiosis and even
rocky mountain spotted fever
which is more mid-atlantic and down into
the southern states
it will help you a lot to remind you
what geography you live in
will give you a clue as to what the
diseases will be that you will come
across
so this map shows the historic
in the light color at the bottom of the
country the southern states
southeast part of texas all the way to
florida
and up into most of the southern states
that was the
up until 10 years ago that was the
geographic
area where the lone star tick occurred
and the darker brown
are where the lone star tick has
migrated to over the past decade
in where i am from which is new england
i'm from massachusetts and
the rhode island area where i work now
10 years ago we never saw hme because we
never saw the lone star tick
in those geographies now look at the
expansion
so these are emerging infectious
diseases
in terms of more and more cases every
year and more and more geographies
and by the way more and more different
germs are out there
you know this this is to remind you that
tick-borne diseases are seasonal
and they peak in the summer is that
important
yes it's important because if you work
in an urgent care setting
an emergency room or you're on the front
lines in some other way if you are in a
tick endemic
area and someone comes in in june or
july and august
complaining of a fever a headache
myalgias
and tells you you feel like they have
the flu
if you diagnose a summer flu in that
patient
you will probably be wrong influenza
is a winter disease and tick-borne
diseases
are summer diseases starting about now
this is early april for the next several
months
depending on where you live in the
country people who present to you with
non-specific
febrile illnesses myalgias headaches
fever
i recommend your assumption be they have
a vector-borne disease and not
the flu i i don't think on nantucket and
cape cod
we should be diagnosing the summer flu
in june and july and august
because we'll probably be wrong so how
do we diagnose
infectious diseases in general
so this is a generalization and
infectious diseases
are diagnosed in essence two different
ways
show me the germ or show me the immune
response to that germ
how do we directly demonstrate the germ
well as you can see on this slide
historically we have used culture
stains nowadays we use pcr and this is
not an exhaustive list
10 years from now we'll be using
next-gen sequencing and so forth
but you can demonstrate the organism in
an
involved tissue and that will help you
make the diagnosis
like a throat culture for example
an indirect way of diagnosing an
infection
the most common thing that will resonate
with you is serologies
acute and convalescent serologies for
example
that's how we diagnose hepatitis b and c
and parabol virus and many diseases we
even diagnose
tuberculosis frequently by skin testing
which is an indirect
cellular immune indirect reaction to the
organism
these principles show me the organism or
show me the immune response to the
organism
carries over to tick-borne diseases as
well
in lyme disease it's difficult to show
the organism directly it's not
impossible
but as i mentioned to you before lyme
disease does not live in the blood
typically and it's a little bit more
difficult and challenging and there is
only a scant number of organisms
so if we rely on serologies mostly for
lyme disease
traditionally we diagnose lyme serol
serologically
early in an infection the germ is there
a patient is sick and
we have better luck in diagnosing most
tick-borne infections by looking for the
germ
the day the patient becomes symptomatic
very early a week later when they're in
the emergency room
when they're in your urgent care center
frequently
we can diagnose tick-borne diseases
by showing me the organism and two weeks
later
three weeks later they will develop
a serologic response the term
window period refers to a period of time
where a patient is infected frequently
symptomatic
the organism is able to be demonstrated
but there is no serologic response at
that time
because it takes two or three weeks to
develop
a detectable immune response and a
positive serology
very important point there so if a
patient is sick
on day one and you order a serologic
test for anaplasma for erlichia for
babesia you will miss
the diagnosis if you order a pcr
you're likely to make the diagnosis
the more acute the more likely you are
to be able to
diagnose this disease by pcr or by
demonstrating the organism
and as weeks go by serology has become
helpful
very important i'm going to show you a
couple of slides that demonstrates that
this slide is not specific to any
infection it's a generalization
the relationship between symptomatic
infections
the left curve and the antibody response
so you are sick for days you have a
positive blood culture for days
and eventually you develop a serologic
response
this is well documented for many
pathogens that you are familiar with
especially today we'll be talking about
the tick-borne diseases
it's true for um hiv it's true for
zika virus it's true for so many
infectious diseases
the germ is there later
zero conversion occurs and the main
point i'm going to emphasize
is that if you order serologies on the
left-hand side
you will miss the infection if you order
serologies and you're too
soon for the antibody response it's not
because
the technology is poor or something's
wrong with this methodology it's because
there is no
immune response until
two weeks three weeks into the infection
there's that phrase window period it's a
period of time when the germ is there
and a patient is seronegative
this is a generalization this is the
sequence of what happens
now some i'll just skip over that now
some pathogens
have a very very narrow window of
bacteremia
or viremia in the case of zika virus
and you only have a few days or a week
to catch that infection an example of
this would be
lyme disease for example lyme disease as
i mentioned is not traditionally
bloodborne it's not trophic for blood
doesn't like to be in your bloodstream
for a long time it's not
at home there it's briefly in your
bloodstream after
a tick bite inoculates you
and you only have a brief amount of time
to pick it up in the bloodstream
this is why we must rely on serologies
for lyme disease we do see patients who
come in and they're both pcr positive
and antibody positive for b bird
dorfried
and guess what one day later or two days
later
their antibody levels are much higher
and their pcr
is now negative pcr for those of you
listening who
aren't familiar with it it's called
polymerase chain reaction
you should view pcr as a molecular
version
of a culture it is a way using
sophisticated molecular
laboratory techniques a direct
demonstration of the organism's dna is
made in the bloodstream think of it as a
molecular culture
well here's a curve that looks a lot
different doesn't it
here's a curve where the bacteria is
there
and then it starts to fade and then
there are multiple
peaks and lowerings and increases so
this
is an example of a germ that lives in
the bloodstream for a long period of
time and overlaps the serologic
response and as you can see in the top
this is
would be very typical
curves from a patient affected with
bodisiosis
remember babisiosis loves your blood
that's where
it's at home in your body it's a
blood-borne disease like
malaria it lives in blood tissue
in erythrocytes and it waxes and waits
for weeks and months and sometimes many
months
giving your antibody response plenty of
time so it's not at all uncommon
to see babesia linger in the bloodstream
this long
it's the opposite part of the spectrum
as lyme disease for example which hates
your bloodstream
and is only there so so transiently
so the symptoms occur
i want to remind you the symptoms will
occur early in the course
if there is our symptoms and there is
the diagnosis
of the illustration of the window period
throughout the whole window period
if you order serologies by definition
they will be negative
so i have a couple of more points to
make on this relationship between
bacteremia
and serologies is it possible
we hypothesize that there would be a
period of time
a window when you would order pcr just a
little bit too late
yet you're a little bit too early for
serology
there is definitely precedent for this
in the infectious disease world
we know for example on zika virus you
are no longer viremic
and there's about a week window where
you're negative by tcr
and you're too early and so you're
negative for serology too
so how do you how do you deal with this
if you have a symptomatic patient
you expect you anticipate a diagnosis of
the tick-borne diseases
and the pcr is negative and the serology
is negative what would you do
i would repeat the serology in a week
notice how helpful a follow-up
convalescent serology will be
in a symptomatic patient in which you
suspect an infection
who is seronegative
and of course the cdc recommendations
and
idsa recommendations are if you suspect
lyme disease and the test is negative
consider doing a convalescent uh
serology test
that's right in the cdc recommendations
so let's talk about specific ways we
diagnose lyme disease
you can culture the germ has minimal
if any clinical utility it has a lot of
research
utility but it takes weeks or a month to
grow
in culture which limits its usefulness
when there's a sick patient in front of
you
what you should know about pcr is that
it detects the organism's specific dna
sequences
the turnaround times are rapid less than
a day
what takes the longest in a pcr test
if you've ever ordered one is getting
the specimen to the lab
once the lab has it they can order it
they can run this test
and report it out rather quickly it's
useful in synovial fluid in the case of
lyme arthritis
it's useful for a few days in blood
you can find it in the skin and then the
csf
most lyme disease is diagnosed
serologically
and traditionally as we will see soon
the serology is involved using elisa
test
and another test called a western blood
i would like to show you what a western
blood is on this slide a western blood
is when you take bieber and put it
essentially on a nitrocellulose strip
long
skinny strip of paper and then you
incubate the patients
you basically dividing the burdorffry up
into
all of its separate antigenic proteins
lipoproteins and
immunogenic areas and you see
if the patient has something in its
serum
that reacts to it antibodies
now these two western bloods look
different don't they
the one on the left and the one on the
right i put these up to make a point
this is of course the same patient's
serum this is a single
blood draw done two different ways by a
western blot
and the reason i put this up is to make
a point
that western blots are very slippery
tests to do
they're difficult to standardize from
one lab to the next
on one strain of bieber dorfry to the
next
they can look very different i
caution you to
not to compare western blood i think
clinicians do fall into traps
occasionally by saying
i did a western blot on a patient and i
did it again six months later
and there was a new band there well
does that mean the patient has a new
infection or has relapsed
or was it just done technically in a
different lab by
a different technician in a different
methodology maybe
there's a lot of difficulties
interpreting western blots
knowing what a positive is agreeing
on whether or not a western blood has
changed
so i'd like you to just reflect on these
two
western blots on the same blood draw on
a given patient
lyme is traditionally as you all know
diagnosed by a two-tiered or two-step
serologic profile and everyone who is in
this business
knows that lyme recommendations are to
start with one test
that's considered to be a pretty
sensitive test because we don't want to
miss
infections and then to confirm it with a
specific test
because we don't want to overcall lyme
disease either we don't want to say
there's false positives so there are two
types
of two-tier tests out there and
sttt stands for
standard two-tier test it's what's been
endorsed by the
fda and the idsa for the past
27 years now 1994. it was based by the
way on a very very small number of
patients
less than 30 positives were in the
studies that led to this
which ban should we count all that sort
of thing that's how far back it dates
historically the fda and researchers and
clinicians
have struggled with interpreting western
blots especially igm western blots
and there's been almost a decade's worth
of research to see what can we do to
improve lyme disease testing it led
to an important announcement about a
year and a half ago by the cdc
endorsing mtt as the modified two-tier
test let's talk about that for a minute
the modified two-tier test has been
shown
in many validation studies to perform
equal to
or superior to the sttt with less
confusion
and no western blot that's its main
advantage so here is the
diagram of the sttd start with one test
on the left hand side and if it is
equivocal or positive do a second tier
test
and the yellow circles are to remind you
that
it is strongly advised not to do igm
western blots in patients who are
symptomatic
more than 30 days because of the number
of false positives and false negatives
the circle at the bottom of this page
reminds you
what i mentioned already that if you
suspect lyme
and the test is negative please do
another test
an acute and convalescent serologies are
invaluable
for many infectious diseases here is a
diagram of the mtt
endorsed since about 2019
and brought up by many commercial labs
in 2020 recently
both tiers are elisa base and there is
no western blood
that is the novel thing this test has
been validated
as mentioned to be as good as or
superior in different stages of lyme
avoiding the potential confusion and
sometimes
misleading results that are seen on
western blots
so current lime testing i'm speaking to
you now
as as you saw from my biography or
bibliography up front
that i work for the northeast division
of sonic
labs which is basically in new york
and in rhode island we introduced about
a year ago
the mtt in our lab and 90
of our volume of
lyme serologies are now mtt
traditional sttt is still available
and there are multiple options on using
on what you would like to use for the
first year and what you would like to
use for the second tier the cdc and idsa
infectious disease society of america
doesn't tell you what
you have to use any approved first-year
test and any approved western black for
the second tier and that's about 10
of our business people have asked me
why do those 10 still use
the sttt um is it more valuable in some
circumstances and i think the answer is
pretty straightforward is that
tradition comfort level what i'm used to
i like i'm comfortable seeing the report
we're all resistant to change some of us
are early adopters
for medications and diagnostic tests and
some of us
are slower adopters of new things
so here's an example of an actual lab
report
that will leave our lab and go into the
hands of an ordering clinician you will
see the name
of the test under the word results in
bold face capital letters
line modified two-tier test and in
parenthesis
mtt and under that you will see tier one
and then even below that because tier
one was
positive tier two gets done tier one
uses an elisa that combines igg and igm
tier two separates igg and igm so there
are more lines or more reports on that
but this is an example
of what a test result a report back to
your clinician
back to your emr whatever would look
like
so before we leave lyme disease
there are a couple of important points
since itg and igm antibodies persist for
years
there is no role for routine follow-up
serologic testing
after you diagnose and treat a patient
for lyme disease
and the reason for that should be
obvious i have lyme arthritis
you diagnose it you treat me i am going
to be seropositive
for another decade or two decades or
longer even igm persists in lyme disease
so what do you learn from a follow-up
serology
and experience has shown and there is
data to support this that
both patients and doctors patients who
get copies of their reports and doctors
get confused
more than helped by follow-up serologic
testing we don't have a blood test
for a cure for lyme disease there are
many unorthodox
unconventional non-validated tests and
the cdc will outline them
on their website and the internet is
full of
unreliable information about lyme
disease now we're going to leave lime
and talk about some of the other
tick-borne diseases
just so you can have a little fun and
take a breather here's some medical
history for you
who is nancy gray i'm not violating
anybody's
privacy here because her story is on the
internet
in the public domain she was a summer
resident of nantucket
at the age of 59 in the summer of 1969
she returned home after spending the
summer in nantucket went to a local
emergency room with an acute illness
the lab tech noted intra-erythrocytic
inclusions a manual differential
the blood was sent to the cdc and
ultimately
diagnosed as the first case of babesia
the microdie
so that was 1969. two well-known doctors
from massachusetts
dr spielman is a public health
epidemiologist
the late dr spellman and dr damon was a
pathologist from
the brigham hospital went to nantucket
solved a lot of the mysteries about this
disease identified the white foot mouse
as the reservoir
a previously unrecognized tick vector
called the deer tick
briefly was called excited stamina after
him
renamed exitus scapularis for some
reason
and lucky he did that lucky these
doctors did that because it paved the
way
and it helped dr steer solve the
transmission of lyme disease three years
later
more cases of obesiosis which the first
name of the ibesiosis was nantucket
fever
clinically it causes symptoms that you
can read on this page
the bottom bullet reminds you that it
there's a lot of the besia can linger in
your bloodstream for a long time
even while you're asymptomatic and you
could potentially donate blood
it could be transfused your unit of
blood could be transfused into a
recipient
and you could cause the busios in a
recipient
so this is an example this is an
exception to the rule
that all these diseases are transmitted
only by
ticks here's the exception it can be
transmitted by blood donation
if you're unlucky how do you diagnose
babesia you look for the organism
or you look for the serology now look at
the bullet i have bold faced in the
bottom
of the top half of the page in acutely
infected patients
they are pcr positive they are smear
positive
the patient is sick the patient may be
hemolyzing
and they are antibody negative i'm
emphasizing this because
if you order a serology at that time you
will be misled you'll say oh i've ruled
out
the besia in this patient if you order a
smear or a pcr
you will make the diagnosis and below
in serology ultimately the patient will
seroconvert
you have seen slides like this before
during your training of babisia
easily demonstrated living inside red
cells
libesia is an emerging and expanding
infection this is one state this is
pennsylvania
most states in the northeast and the
upper midwest are showing graphs like
this
let's talk about hga human granulocytic
anaplasmosis
it was first identified in the upper
midwest by a
friend and colleague of mine dr johann
bakken
former president of the idsa the
american
society for in fact clinical for
infectious disease
infectious disease the first case in
the northeast was on nantucket by a guy
i still work with dr
lepri it's called the g and granulocytic
means that's where it lives and it's
doxycycline responsive
unlike babesia
clinical spectrum no rash no
arthritis acute flu-like illness
you will be tempted to say that this
patient has a summer flu
no in july in coastal rhode island
on cape cod on nantucket with or without
other clues
that you see on a cbc
not all patients have a low platelet
count but it's an important clue to us
not all patients have the elevations and
transaminations but it's a
very important clue a lot of people get
sick with this and get better
but if you are frail or immunosuppressed
or on dialysis or have a splenectomy
it is potentially a fatal disease there
are lots of fatalities from this disease
in frail patients
let me go back one side i would like to
emphasize that there is no known chronic
phase of hga
i mentioned that because i see doctors
order
all the tick-borne disease tests
everything for patients with
chronic arthritis chronic fatigue
for anaplasma for erlichia for
they don't cause arthritis they don't
cause chronic symptoms
it's a waste of medical resources to
order
um to order tests that have that are
total non-fit
for a patient's presentation
just because lyme is on your
differential diagnosis doesn't mean
hga hme and the others are on here
how do you diagnose anaplasma same as
all these
infections we're talking about acutely
infected patients are pcr-positive and
antibody negative
i have seen many cases in my career of
patients in the icu
or in emergency rooms where a doctor
will
ask a clerical person to order a blood
test for anaplasma
and because of a breakdown in
communications a serology gets ordered
by mistake
comes back negative and the patient
remains acutely sick until another
doctor will order the pcr and make the
diagnosis
it's a beautiful picture isn't it of an
anaplasma
intragranular inclusion
which somebody that's experienced at
looking at smears will be able to pick
up there's not a lot of them
and it's not easy to see unless you
stumble upon it but when you see it it's
diagnostic
hme got its name and it's
caused the name of the germ is erlickia
chaffiensis because the first case was
in a military recruit from fort chaffee
in arkansas
the m stands for monocytes it is
doxycycline responsive
we never saw it in the dark brown areas
on the map i previously showed you
until the tick started expanding and
moving north
now we see it in new england
if you could tell this disease from
anaplasma or miyamoto
on the basis of looking at the patient
you're better than me
because it's hard to tell
when someone walks in with a febrile
illness and no rash
and they look sick how can i tell by
looking at the patient if it's hme
hga miyamoto or babisia i can't tell
this star this graph uh sorry these
comments
resemble the comments on hga a lot of
people can get better by themselves and
a lot of people will succumb to this if
they're very frail and immunosuppressed
slightly different geography can't get
hme unless you live in a region where
the lone star tick is
you've seen this slide before you
diagnose it in an acutely infected
person
by pcr and eventually they will see or
convert
brilliant mia motoi we briefly mentioned
first human cases in 2011 in russia
first new england north american case
was in a patient diagnosed in 2012 and
reported in the new england journal
medicine in 2013.
there's a lot of burgeoning literature
on this new pathogen
this looks like some of the other slides
too no rash
non-specific flu-like illness a couple
of
clues and you can see the publication i
reference to you
it can make these diseases mimic each
other
i'm bringing that up because i need
help from the laboratory to know what
which patient is infected with me a
motive versus hga versus
hme versus vibesia they have
they don't all have the exact same
treatment and they have different
implications
i can't look at a patient and say oh
this patient has hga
and look at another patient and say this
is hme
i've showed you this before acutely sick
patients are pcr-positive and
sero-negative
so all of the germs to summarize the
laboratory diagnosis of these all of
these germs
have in common when they're acutely sick
you need to rely on pcr and eventually
they will seroconvert
so here's i'm going to finish by talking
about
the last topic is co-infections so
here's a patient
that i was lucky enough to have this
camera in hand right it doesn't get more
perfect or textbook than this
so the question is if you saw this rash
would you order a blood test that's the
question
and of course the joke that goes with it
the doctor says
it looks like it might be an arrow
through your head but just to be sure
i'm going to order some blood tests well
the reason
i order tests in patients who have
classic em
is not to diagnose lyme disease just to
make sure they don't have something else
because co-infections are so common i'll
show you a little bit of data here
this is from my old lab in 2016.
if you look at the left you'll see we
cast the net of all
patients who had acute lyme disease and
you can see on the right
six point three percent were also
pcr-positive
or blood if you will blood culture
positive
for babesia and so forth
if you look at babesia patients um
47 percent of babesia patients either
had old antibody saline or were
co-infected with lyme it's not
rare so let's leave my data from my old
lab and talk about mayo clinic data
if they look that they looked at a
series of babisi acacias
two years ago look at the numbers that
were co-infected
with the other pathogens it's not
trivial
if i have a case of babesia and 24
of them also have lime or five or eight
percent have
other pathogens or multiple pathogens
for me these numbers
are big enough to make me want to look
for these other germs
therefore laboratories
will offer you ways to group
tests there are acute tick-borne disease
panels to use in the summertime
a typical acute panel might look like
this molecular tests
by various methodologies you could do
them individually you can do them
you can fuse probes and primers and do
multiplex
don't worry about the methodologies
worry about the concept look for the
germ
if you think a patient is acutely
symptomatic
why does the acute panel also have a
serology for lyme because
the window to pick it up in the blood is
so brief it's commonly missed by
whole blood pcr so we're never going to
escape the need for serology
as one of the things we rely on to
diagnose lyme disease
so here are the core technologies
in acutely sick patients
antibodies and everything else is pcr
for the other pathogens now let's just
suppose
a new germ were to evolve next year and
became
increasing emerged high prevalence it
could be added as another
pcr should that happen which it is
happening
i'd like to end by giving you a few
pieces of advice and common pitfalls
the first pitfall is ordering the wrong
test i have a patient with chronic
arthritis oh what the heck
i'll order the whole panel and get all
the germs well the besia hga hme those
neomotoy they don't cause arthritis they
don't cause chronic anything
why are you looking for them if they are
a total non-fit
for the patient chronic fatigue workup
why would you ever look for hga i have
no idea
i think it's a mistake to do ig west igm
western blots
at all because i have not ordered one
myself in over two decades
because i think it's an unreliable test
and so does the cdc and idsa
and we are all discouraged from doing
them after
30 days of symptoms unfortunately
laboratory requisitions
don't ask that question we don't capture
that information on a requisition
is your patient symptomatic more than 30
days if we did
we would not do igm western blots
doing follow-up serologies and
retreating for residual positive
antibodies because
they're zero positive forever
in believing all the information getting
led astray on the internet
so here are some other emerging
chick-form diseases
i'm just throwing them up here for you
to see what's coming down the pike
there are other borrelia species
mayonnaise
obviously discovered by researchers at
the mayo clinic
another virus called the heartland virus
prewasing virus is here now
so there are some of the other
tick-borne diseases that you
will learn more about i think in the
future it's not going to go away
my last slide is just a timeline for
these other diseases
when the ticks were discovered the besio
being the first
and you can follow this timeline to the
right and who knows where it's going to
go from here
so that's going to conclude the formal
part of my talks
and i wanted to make sure i ended long
enough i hope that
the host of our meeting will remind you
that this is going to be archived and
available
for you to listen to and view again in
the future but i'm going to pause here
and let
michelle or jennifer take over and go
into some questions if you have any
thank you dr malloy for your informative
presentation
and we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
so there's no cure for tbd does it
survive in the blood indefinitely
so that's not exactly the question is
not exactly true
there's no cure for tbd that's not an
incorrect
that's not a correct statement all these
diseases are curable
there is no what i meant to say and i
hope i said we can go back and look at
those slides later is that there's no
blood test to prove i'm cured
just like there's no blood test to prove
i'm cured from tb
or syphilis if you give me a standard
curative treatment for syphilis my vdrl
is still positive
it's an antibody based test if you treat
me for
tb with whatever regimen and cure me of
tb my skin test is still positive so we
don't have a blood test
to prove you're cured but yes
these are all curable diseases
thank you dr molloy our next question
so when lyme serology remains positive
for years
how do you diagnose new lyme in someone
who has tested positive before besides
clinically
can you use the same mtt test as the
baseline and compare igg and igm levels
that's a great question and it's very
challenging question
and there is the short answer is no
um you are stuck being a clinician and
making the judgment
um the only way you can rely on
serologies
is if a patient eventually zero reverted
in other words enough
years went by and their antibodies faded
you treated them early they didn't have
enormous
sky high levels of antibodies years went
by and now they're zero negative and
then they become zero positive again
it's very difficult to say my igg level
or my iga level
or igm level was a certain number let's
say
four or five and now it's a seven
um unless they're done on the same test
run and nobody archives
specimens in a freezer for years there
were labs that did that at one time but
no longer if i had your blood test from
five years ago i would fart out if i had
that specimen
i would thaw it out and i could tease it
out
but it's there are pitfalls and it's not
reliable to say
a certain number was four a few years
ago and now it's a seven or an eighth
because that's not statistically a
different number if it was done with
different batches of reagents
on different years so you're left doing
the best you can clinically
thank you dr malloy our next question
can pcr give false positives oh oh my
screen jump there we go
again pcr against positive since this is
detecting fragments
and not the patient's ability to keep
pathogens from producing symptoms
that's a good question and i think there
are probably two parts to the question
if not i'm going to answer it in two
parts um a pcr can be false positive
in a way a false positive means i'm
detecting a signal into something that
isn't there
so if i have lyme arthritis and you tap
my joint and demonstrate
it's a positive pcr meaning that the
organism's dna is in my bloodstream
and you treat me and cure me
and right away do another aspiration of
my joint
the pcr is still going to be positive
because i have
fragments of previously live but now
decaying dna
in my blood in my joint fluid that will
still
result in a positive signal if you wait
long enough your body will resorb and
digest
dna fragments dna fragments don't live
forever in your blood or synovial fluid
so yes in that situation
you might think it would be a pulse
false positive i would
not look at that as a false positive i
would say it's a true positive
for what you are testing the dna is
still there
but the patient is treated i i like to
wait before i do another joint tap
and look i would wait a month or two and
then i know
then i expect the dna to be gone now a
false positive view might mean something
else
are you coming up with a signal for one
of these germs
when it it's not there and it never was
there and
i would like to say that never happens
in an ideal lab it never happens
the only way that happens is if i
contaminate it if i have a contamination
issue in the lab i won't die i won't get
a positive signal for babesia in your
bloodstream
unless there's babesia there or i've
contaminated the specimen
the labs goes through in inordinate
we don't do babesia smears or cultures
or
anywhere near where we're doing pcrs or
our molecular work
so and and the thermocyclers
are closed systems now they're not open
so
the lab does extraordinary things to
avoid contamination right now
so the only way you could get a real
false positive is by contamination and
i'm not sure that happens
these days it did though 10 or 15 years
ago
but labs do a good job at with protocols
to avoid contamination and we
get surveyed and get accreditation
that's part of our accreditation and
make sure we're not we don't do that
thank you dr malloy our next question do
different western
western blot tests look for different
antigenic targets
and what is the correlation between
bands kilo dalton and antigenic
targets um
an antigen is something that stimulates
your immune system and that's what's on
the piece of paper
and that's what you make antibodies do
and that shows up as a band
so i think it's sort of a fluid term an
antigen
is a word we use about the compound the
molecule
that is stimulating your immune system
and the band is the reaction
that we're seeing on the piece of paper
and
there is there are dozens of strains of
bieber dorfry
out there and and there are different
stages of being propagated
and they are drift and different strains
have
bands at different molecular weights and
the ways that these strips are
prepared it's not as standardized and as
rigid as you
think that is the point
thank you dr malloy what is the
recommended test for a patient suspected
with lyme disease
is t is the tbd panel test for
the preferred order so to rule out other
non-lyme diseases
so that's a good question too and if it
was the summer time if it was
memorial day to labor day in a super
endemic
area i'm not sure where this question
came from but if you're on cape cod or
long island or
coastal new jersey or some place that's
really hot
i would always look for co-infections
yes i would do that if you have a
patient in the winter with a swollen
joint and you want to make sure it's not
lyme disease
i would order a lime serology and that's
what the guidelines suggest
to rule out lyme arthritis or chronic
neurologic lyme do a lyme serology
in an acute patient who's been sick for
one week
look for co-infections
thank you dr malloy it looks like we
have time for just a few more questions
the next question how do you communicate
to physicians the difference in
interpretation when they are used to
looking at bands on the western blot
well change is difficult for everyone
and it's difficult to let go of things
that you're used to and it's difficult
for me to turn in my old junk car and
ride a new one
because i like my old car and even if it
breaks down
and that's i i would tell doctors that
um
i would ask a doctor um how much
help he got from the last igm western
blood
or do you ever get confused by western
bloods
or does it ever come back and surprise
you i can tell you if you take a single
specimen
from a patient who's had lyme put it in
the freezer
that single specimen and do an igg
western plot on it
12 times once a month for the next year
they'll be drift they're not all going
to be identical bands
and i see that in the lab and knowing
that
makes me happy to transition
from western blood to the mtt
thank you dr malloy our next question
uh see is blood the usual sample for the
pcr test for lyme even though the
bacteria is not trophic to the blood
so for the first week of lyme disease it
could be in the blood
it's the only specimen because you're
not going to do a
it's causing heart block we're not going
to get cardiac tissue
and most of you are not going to be
doing synovial biopsies or aspirations
and sending that
by the time it's a swollen joint
synovial fluid and blood are the two
most reasonable specimens
thank you dr malloy and we have time for
one more question
if in lyme disease the infection is in
the blood for a brief time
where does it go next and why can't we
do a pcr for this area
um it does go to the skin and you can do
a pcr for the skin
um it just is invasive that's all if you
do
punch biopsies of the skin it's very
reliable
when it goes elsewhere in the body it's
not
it's not as accessible if you could
biopsy tissues
with no downside i would i would do it
more often
first of all one of my slides said
there's a scant
number of organisms even when it's in
the joint
it's very scant that's why we have to
amplify the dna sequences the specific
dna sequences
um that's a good conceptual question
i think the answer is it's just too hard
to find and it's just
this one organism a pathologist looks at
a
500 visual fields you might come across
one or two organisms it's just too hard
to hunt it down
and the other side of that question is
it's very immunogenic to your immune
system so the
immune response is very reliable as the
weeks go by
and the hunt for the dna of lyme is very
difficult
thank you dr malloy do you have any
final comments for our audience
no thank you for listening in and i hope
you found the presentation
uh useful and even if you would like to
go back and listen to it again thank you
thank you again dr malloy for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank labrus and
our sponsor diazoran molecular llc
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
please join us for our second webinar
next week on april 9th
implementation of a multiplex molecular
test for anaplasma
babesia and erlichia before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye